- [Victor] This world can
make you feel alone sometimes,
but I think the most
important thing to do in life
is always be there when
somebody needs you.
- [Ginger] I had been driving
by him for almost three years.
He would stand there rain or shine.
I decided I needed to stop
and find out why he was there.
- [Victor] I used to stand
right there on that corner.
My mother would meet me there
sometimes whenever she could.
That's just a place that she could meet me
if ever she was looking for me.
- [Ginger] Because he couldn't find her,
he just wanted to make sure
she knew that he was okay,
which I thought was so beautiful.
He has this wisdom that
comes up from inside of him
that can only come from love
that is just unconditional.
(gentle music)
- [Patrick] We were getting
phone calls from people
who were saying, "get
this guy off your corner."
Everyone on my crew would
check on him on a daily basis.
- [Bodak] What's going on?
- [Victor] Alright.
- [Man] Victor, how are you today?
- [Victor] I'm doing good,
I'm glad to see everybody.
- [Patrick] Some would go in
the morning and check on him
and then go back in the evening.
He'd ask us how we were doing,
and we would ask him how he
was doing and what he needed.
He stood on the corner,
people gave him money,
but he didn't want the money.
Victor said, "I'm just waiting on my mom."
And as soon as we told all
those people the story,
the outpour from this
community was enormous.
(inspirational music)
- [Ginger] Last Thanksgiving,
when I drove up on the corner
where he was, I think he
had enough food to feed
probably five families.
It was all spread out all over the ground,
and he was just standing
there in the middle of it.
There were so many people in our community
that cared about him, but he
didn't need another sandwich.
He needed that next step.
It was at that point that my husband said,
"You know, I really feel like
"he needs to come and stay with us."
This is a lifelong journey.
Victor is part of my family.
He has a mother.
One is enough, he told me.
And so we've decided
that I'm the big sister.
- It's like coming home
and you just try to be
a nice person ‘cause you treat people like
you like to be treated.
- You told me that you were my gift.
- Yeah, I am your gift, you know?
- Yes, you are my gift.
- Yeah, because...
Yeah, if you believe, only if you believe.
- Aww.
(Victor laughs)
- We've gotten to know so many people
in our community because of Victor.
A dentist did a tremendous
amount of dental work for him.
A karate studio gave him tai chi lessons.
- [Patrick] We're a close-knit community,
we take care of our own.
Victor was one of our own.
- [Ginger] Victor and
I, we stopped and cared
about each other.
That's what friends do.
- [Victor] Friends come and
go, so you need the ones
that are gonna stick by you.